it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor author of the
new book The Unexpected light of Thomas
Alva Edison Raymond Arroyo all right Ray
Kamala Harris is on another critical
foreign Mission I understand well this
time Laura the VP is in Africa to try to
blunt Chinese dominance on the continent
but if this is all that stands between
the Africans in China I hope they have
an ear for Mandarin listen
excited about the future of
Africa on the rest of the world
including the United States of America
there are a number of things on the edge
of the economy as a whole
that we must do and a lot of that work
is the work that I'm here to do on the
continent
let's hope that work includes using
sentences that stack up Laura to convey
more than one thought she has a real
comfort with like one idea being
expressed over and over and over again
kind of jumbling the words but it's the
same thing I don't know why she speaks
so much just say the one line and go
home I think that someone is trying to
undermine her whoever is writing her
materials seems not to be a fan of
kamalos that is my theory on all of this
well you know she's like a stylist
caught in the groove of a record you
know it just keeps repeating over and
over inflation went from one percent to
nine percent now it's six percent here
in the United States on Kamala Harris's
watch but if the VP has no plan for
Ghana she did release Laura and I wish I
were making this up a Spotify playlist
of African artists to Mark her trip now
the titles of the songs are Illuminating
they include Act a Fool Reckless and
sweet fall and nobody that is probably a
more apt description of this visit than
I could conjure up even myself thinking
all day long I'll just leave those there
you can marinate on them well Raymond I
thought Paul and nobody fall and nobody
could actually just be Joe and Kamala
that's kind of the that's kind of sums
up the ticket
um well and it when in doubt Kamala
throws out the Stardust Raymond
according accompanying her on this trip
is British actor Idris Elba and TV star
sherilee Ralph what yeah they visited a
recording studio today Laura that's
going to save the continent for sure but
this is the problem while foreign actors
move against the United States and the
economy spirals the Biden team thinks
they can Dazzle Americans by inviting
stars to surround them the other day the
president threw out National Medals of
Arts to everyone from Bruce Springsteen
to Julia Louis-Dreyfus who the White
House gladly featured online watch this
incredible honor of just about from Duck
congratulations congratulations thank
you sir thank you congratulations
Laura the White House built that as
three vice presidents past and present
are in one room do they realize she
played a moronic goofball of a vice
president who screwed everything up that
was Louis dreyfus's world and Veep she
was a disaster
now doesn't care for that show what else
right yeah well and and speaking of
celebrities Gwyneth Paltrow is causing a
stink in a courtroom without even
lighting one of her crotch scented
candles she's taking the stand in a 300
thousand dollar lawsuit over a 2016 ski
slope Collision a man claims Paltrow ran
into him and skied away and his Lord his
lawyer seems to be auditioning to be a
goop sales representative may I ask how
tall you are I'm just under 5 10. okay I
am so jealous I have to wear four inch
heels just to make it to five five
you're small But Mighty
actually you're not that small I want to
talk with you about the counter claim
and he has deterred you from enjoying
the rest of what was a very expensive
vacation
well I lost half a day of skiing okay
and I'm assuming
in your under oath here that you're a
good Tipper yes okay fantastic I
wouldn't expect anything less
Laura this lawyer Kristen Van oremen is
either a brilliant cross-examiner or
Gwyneth needs to get a restraining order
against her I don't know which but this
is something else I've never seen
courtroom drama like this my question to
you is you know my eight week
anniversary of my surgery is Wednesday
and must you bring up a ski accident I
don't care if a celebrity is involved
well I'm glad there was no other party
involved but your son it keeps it out
all right Raymond and I know you're at
the Reagan Library signing your book
Wednesday night so people can catch you
there details at Raymond arroyo.com
we're going to see you Wednesday night
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else